holding the presidency of the g20
indonesia's president joko widodo has
positioned himself at the center of
global events
after meeting with leaders of the g7
last week he undertook shuttle diplomacy
between the combatants in the ukraine
war seeing for himself the destruction
in the town of irpin outside the capital
kiev
it's very sad a lot of houses and
infrastructure are broken we hope no
other ukraine cities will be ravaged
because of the war then to moscow for
talks with russian president vladimir
putin
as a leading force in the so-called
non-aligned movement of nations
indonesia believes it could act as a
bridge between the two sides
participation in g20 summit meeting
will be a very valuable opportunity for
the russian government
to address its own position to the rest
of the world
and which is not
only advantageous to put in government
of russia but it may be quite conducive
to
all warring party in the ukraine crisis
russia's foreign minister sergey lavrov
is due to hold bilateral meetings with
some of his counterparts but
significantly not with u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken the last time the
two met was in a tense encounter in
january when lavrov gave his assurance
russia had no plans to invade ukraine a
month before it did just that the g20
came into being in part to deal with the
fallout from economic crises that the g7
couldn't handle on its own especially in
recent times this gathering takes place
as the world is now facing the perfect
storm of global challenges
the ukraine war threatens a worldwide
food crisis and indonesia like many
countries is heavily reliant on grain
from the region
the war is also helping push up energy
costs that are driving inflation
added to that ongoing tensions in the
indo-pacific with china increasingly
confronting its neighbours and nato at
its last meeting promising to push back
in this idyllic island setting the world
is looking for solutions to some
nightmarish scenarios with any signs of
progress being welcomed right now rob
mcbride al jazeera bali